why coffee yeah why is that the is it to
kind of stand out you were like [ __ ] it
no yeah because like cloak makes sense
right because you know that's that's the
thing that that's a move i think that
youtubers have been trying to make for a
very i mean yeah i also made that move
as well yeah like the coffee thing i
think know what was expecting yeah i
i just really liked coffee for a really
long time and i initially was like
thinking of whiskey mm-hmm and i was
like oh that would have been yeah
youtuber whiskey yeah
and i it's just so much harder like
there's actually laws around it yeah
yeah
my audience probably wouldn't even
like 40 of them probably wouldn't even
be able to drink it right right getting
into different places would be
impossible and then i was like i kept
thinking about coffee and i was like
what if we made like top of the morning
coffee
i was like okay that [ __ ] name is too
good i have to do it yeah okay yeah and
then it was a part of that like nobody
else was doing it and i was like it sets
me apart from other people and it's
different they're just doing merch and
clothes right right it's just a fun
thing that i had no idea about and like
learning how it was made and
that i just had my own coffee yeah i
could if it's the same itself i get free
coffee all the time yeah yeah yeah
extremely successful i assume yeah thank
you
thank you i get free coffee every day
was there was any like challenges that
you didn't anticipate starting a company
like this that has like nothing to do
with youtube yeah it's initially it was
like coffee's like a food item yeah it's
it has to be shipped as fresh and quick
as possible right so when we started the
shipping to england was a nightmare
because we have to pay import charges
and everything right and it would take
like a month to get it to people right
and then it would cost extra so shipping
here costs like twice as much as the
coffee itself right um and it was like
starting a company you have to start
really small especially when it's
something that you haven't done before
and we had no like infrastructure really
for it initially so we it's it's made in
like uh
in america and it's made in like
nebraska and stuff
yeah it was shipping from there and that
was the only place that we're shipping
from so we had to figure out a new
method to get it to people cheaper right
we thankfully did and all that feedback
initially was like really really helpful
yeah but as soon as it went up everyone
was super pumped about it and then all
that day i was miserable
because everyone was like this [ __ ]
sucks it's so expensive it doesn't ship
here you don't right
yeah yeah yeah like the site went down
and i spent the whole day being like man
i spent so long like prepping this and
yeah like emotionally attached to it
yeah like trying to like put out fires
all day yeah yeah no matter how much you
make your merch though there's always
that oh it's too expensive yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i mean we don't have this like
gigantic west system in every single
town yeah walmart we can't just get [ __ ]
to you extremely well that was the thing
is like trying to educate people while
also like sympathizing with them trying
to meet them halfway with yeah
everything and yeah
like not trying not to get too businessy
with them right
listen the breakdown costs right you
understand
our profit and loss
we're in debt yeah
well like i guess i i want to like as a
youtuber how do you even like start to
like
like like okay yeah yeah coffee guys
okay because like i think okay but maybe
like one day maybe we'll start like the
trash taste coffee company i don't know
what it's going to be called but like
okay so there i'll i'll just phone my
coffee gu
who do i do who's my coffee guy who do i
talk to
yeah yeah like where did you even like
start
yeah did you just like meet a dude who
was like oh by the way i'm very
interested in starting a coffee company
well there was a company that was doing
it with brooke dodger right oh okay they
were doing it with smosh as well
um and that was another thing like a
review for the coffee came out and
somebody was like there's like a big
coffee guy on youtube and i have his
book he taught me so much about coffee
and i thought he was great and then he
was like youtubers getting into coffee
what does the business look like
and it was all like he didn't actually
start his own coffee company like he
used this other company to like source
the beans and everything and i was like
yeah i said that like
i don't think i was dishonest like did
people think i was going to like go to
the farm myself and like
change business videos if you're just
like touching the beans yeah yeah just
like yeah handpicked by jackson yeah
like i did start a company that has like
its own official documents and yeah i
don't i didn't like buy a roastery on my
own roasters
like i think they expected a bit more
out of it
yeah yeah yeah but yeah they were like
handling coffee for people already and
we were
my agents at the time were like they
they just do everything for everybody
right right um and they they kind of
knew a couple of people who were certain
coffee companies already and they were
like we can put you in touch with all
these people and then
uh akira coffee who are doing the one
that is we're working with now they had
done dodgers and when i talked to them
they just seemed so genuine and nice and
open about it and they they got it and
it wasn't all about like cranking money
out of people and right right it was
just really honest like genuine fun to
do so now the question is how did dodger
get in touch with her
yeah we'll go back to life
well we'll work our way up yeah yeah
exactly but technically yeah i had a
coffee guide today
okay okay it makes things a lot easier
there's always somebody you know who
knows somebody you know right put you in
touch with the right people yeah and if
not you can always just tweet it out
hey i want to find someone in the future
some coffee see like i've tried that a
few times where you're just like you
need a guy and like you tweet it out you
know is this is there any
and and like you get everything but that
guy
most of the tweets are just like
i don't i'm not the guy but good luck
and i'm just like why why are you
replying to this twitter thread it's
always like i'm not that guy but i do
have a fiverr account i can make you
some artwork for it if that's okay with
you
thanks but no here's my fan cam that i
did